[Music]
and lazy loser news this loser that's me
you work so damn hard you're all mine
you're you're on the all-girl podcast
called hey [ __ ] so make sure to check
it out particularly go I'm a nerd
submitted by adidas swoosh I don't like
it he's the funny guy you know what I
pictured those bootleg clothing oh it's
bad yeah adidas with the Nikes yeah a
taxi driver was fired after faking a
heart attack to get out of a small fare
trip Oh can't you just say get out oh
I'm having you better get out the car
yeah that would actually make it take a
longer because I'd be like I'm gonna
call 911 I get the ambulance no no it's
okay I've had this before no no no
really I'm just having a heart attack
it's fine please tell me this video yeah
[ __ ] sorry yep this happened in Sydney
Australia yes Australia let me show you
guys this video clip also well let me
tell you before so he dammit - I'm sorry
he picks her up from the airport but he
immediately wanted to drop her off in
the middle of nowhere once you realize
how short the trip was which I'm
thinking of is that short one I just
[ __ ] chopper up yeah whatever I'm not
driving yes no no no you're a liar you
said you wanted to tell me
you said you wanted a large affair than
the airport Allendale Oh drop it
why solicitor like we should say so you
have a rebuttal he also knows me in film
so he's like making sure his face
doesn't look weird he's keeping his face
very symmetrical and like listening to
her while he has a heart attack yeah
[ __ ] amazing that's pretty funny
she's dope for not giving a [ __ ] about
his whack ass powers great really happy
nuts that would be good
he may be sick as [ __ ] that would be I
mean how would you feel about yourself
after that oh I feel so I still blame
the dude I'm like human eyes all you
want to be right in the middle of
nowhere yeah why does he have to act
like so bad acting this happened to me
when I was in I was an ice I don't know
I wasn't [ __ ] somebody I know I went
to Norway and Sweden I was in Sweden no
no it was like like uber driver we were
me and my buddy tipsy bartender we're
going from the airport to our hotel and
like we're not even like a mile away
from the airport we're like hey man
wants to fare how much is it gonna be to
the thing and he gives us like a crazy
he's like 500 bucks basically and we're
like no [ __ ] way surgery's not big
enough for it to cost 500 oh dude thank
you so so then he's like well we're
gonna drop you off right here so he
dropped us off like like a mile from the
airport so then yeah so we had to like
I'm I got my rolling thing and we're
like carrying a bunch of [ __ ] you
already got
in the taxi when he told you yeah yeah
yeah cuz it took him a minute to like I
don't know they do taxi scams out there
I heard that there were a nice country
dude they are nice so the then that this
is like a random guy then the cops like
we had been walking for like 20 minutes
well you actually just said [ __ ] it I
rather walk yeah oh yeah I would have
scammed him I would have been like okay
and then I would have walked out oh
that's oh yeah once you get there but he
might he might be like let me see the
money you know right well when the cops
come and you tell them about ridiculous
yes they're like as he's making the jail
like partway into the trip he's like
well let me see that you got it true so
yeah so then the cops like we were
walking for like 15 20 minutes and then
the cops like stopped us like what the
[ __ ] you guys doing out here and then we
told him the thing and then they drove
us back in there very cool and then they
were like apologize they apologize on
behalf of the country and they said that
they wanted to get the guy's number they
think that they'll know how to figure
out who that was because it's dispatch
yeah because if it was Mexico the cops
come up and then they'll say how much
money you got in and they'd drive away
and yeah they leave you in the snow
amazing and take your luggage yeah if it
was Japan the cops will take you and
then give you a [ __ ] and then 500
spending money and polish your shoes
reserves Japan not Canada oh I see but
they'd suck your dick yeah well and give
you moose milk or something that's nice
yeah how is that maple syrup moose milk
okay
you know they talk like really big about
their maple syrup cookies I think it was
that special don't you love it by the
way don't you love it when someone's
like our thing is the [ __ ] gonna try it
and you get to look at them and go for
this things and I'm all like yeah it's
my [ __ ] identity and then you're like
guess what good for me cuz I've done
that a lot I got to LA and every time
I've been met with aggression so it
doesn't feel good from one person from a
lot of people
to many many people not one person know
because Jessica's like this I've never
seen it feels that way is what he's
saying yeah so anyways this taxi driver
here so the woman reported the incident
and so the company checked out the
drivers logs and it was clear that the
timestamps matched the passengers claim
and so the driver was pulled in for an
investigation and that's when they when
he couldn't justify his action that's
when they fired him Oh yep yeah that's
some good-ass regulation and also the
taxi deputy chief executive person said
that drivers aren't allowed to refuse a
passenger because of a short journey the
only time cab drivers can reject a job
is if the driver is finishing up their
shift
doctor you know when you like additions
right you know when you lie and then you
get proven like though I know [ __ ]
and then you're still sticking with your
lying like it's so [ __ ] up that you
didn't believe I really did so flip if
you don't believe me and you still want
to stick to it cuz your ego so yeah ya
know cuz you still want to project the
blame onto them so you're like it's
[ __ ] up that you're so cynical that
you won't believe mine fall for my life
like what if I was really having a heart
attack
you [ __ ] yeah yeah that's like why
not I wasn't having a heart attack but
what if I was it's [ __ ] beanie this is
how you're gonna treat me yeah I do that
to him when he doesn't answer his phone
more far apart I'm like he owes cuz I
never called him I'm like hey what if I
was like something was happening and you
don't answer your phone what if I could
be dead and they get mad at the
hypothetical hmm I mean he's like you're
not dead it's exactly you don't even
care no I do care
yeah yeah I mean it just sounds [ __ ]
ludicrous at this point that's funny
he's gotta stick with it why not yeah
cuz at that point you're like basically
you put the concrete down
you make up an imagination as you're
talking to a man I don't get mad it's
not mad it's hurt this is the religion
of stubborn people yeah yeah you know
what was a reason yep yeah that's like
when you're a kid and then you want to
stick to the lie and then you know you
got caught but it's easy to just blame
the other person always funny [ __ ] ever
at least he got fired so he's not doing
that [ __ ] again
or at least not as a taxi driver he's an
uber driver dude the bitchiest thing
like the pussiest thing I ever did I we
were watching wrestling I was a kid all
WWF in jail and I jackknife my buddy
through a closet door and then one my
can you tell me what a jack jackknife is
when you like pick them up like this
edge down between your legs and then
like go upside down yeah it's like a
powerbomb jackknifing through them
through the closet door like head and
shoulders first broke that [ __ ] thing
at half right think this [ __ ]
collapse right and then my parents and
everybody's like what the [ __ ] Steven
all the [ __ ] and then you know cuz you
got to stick with you guys you try to
figure out a way to deflect blame or
whatever so I'm like man like this
wrestling [ __ ] I guess it's really that
I thought it was an attempt no it didn't
[ __ ] work that was my attempt right
I'm like man [ __ ] thought that would
work is amazing
thank you I'm like this [ __ ] [ __ ]
influences me in ways I didn't realize I
was like 12 or 3 what do they say
damn they're like you seen it doesn't
[ __ ] matter that's the stupidest [ __ ]
I wear that day didn't buy it for one
second I thought that would be like oh
you know a wrestling taught me Steve
yeah the [ __ ] take user that's tight
that's a different upbringing but but
yeah yeah but that's the thing that I
learned from school because at school my
teachers were like that like do you know
when you're watching that's like
influencing thing
and you do that fate guilty like that
fake guilt when you're like I knew it
that wrestling just got to me man it was
like an after-school special
like I'm so ashamed of myself yep I
think I'm thinking that right now and
I'm like [ __ ] I think I busted the
middle child syndrome on them the
religion of stubborn people I think
that's what I did I was just like well
it's you know I think it's just my way
of showing love that I need love so good
yeah just about the music kind of
[ __ ] Bilbo what is it I always use
the devil possessed me that they believe
that really oh [ __ ] were cool they were
so religious oh you know what I just got
catalyzed by Satan just for that second
that would be such that's why I had to
beat up my friend and they're like damn
it now we're all gonna have to pray and
I'm like I know like while we're praying
and I feel like my parents like getting
angry I mean I'm like I'm gonna get
[ __ ] up and then they say Amen all
right now it's time for your spanking
boom I'm like [ __ ] do you know doesn't
[ __ ] the Catholic Church yeah hey this
priest was caught in diddling the kid or
whatever the Catholic priest yep yeah
you're like well Satan he got it in me
man yeah he really got it be good I got
into my hands man made me do things to
their body part the devil out yeah it's
like you're not even a Jim Carrey movie
dude yeah the [ __ ] mask yeah give me
a break
[Music]
[Music]